this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
I love the superheroes down at Mann's
Chinese Theater or whatever they're
calling it these days
THC theater no it's something else now
that's a Manson's PVC theater XY TLC
theater TCL I better think it's still
Grauman's I don't like it's bands no
it's some [ __ ] name now it's all
changed anyway I love the superheroes to
hang out in front because they're just
horrible people and they're they're
hideous and downtrodden and awful and
did just they're beaten down and broken
people but they put on the costumes of
superheroes just to try to make a buck
yeah and it bums you out like I've lived
very close to to take that turn all the
time right in front of the wax museum in
Grauman's in Chicago so when you take
the turn off the strip you'll see the
people who are taken like their
10-minute break or whatever yeah and
it's always so [ __ ] sad you'll see
spider-man with his mask off smoking a
cigarette yeah it's rough and you're
like number one I know your secret
identity like your smoke cools you know
but in any event you'll see a bunch of
them just see Darth Vader blowing a guy
for five bucks behind a dumpster but my
thing is like don't take off the mask
ever as ever if you're gonna put on the
mask like find a way to smoke through
well that's even worse
don't [ __ ] smoke until you get home
like honor the colors is what is what
you're saying well they did not honor
the colors this week on Hollywood
Boulevard when there was a cop car
parked in front of Grauman's Chinese
Theater and a madman an insane person
broke into the cop car to steal their
laptop which if you're gonna steal a
laptop out of a car I don't know I'd
pick a car that's not a [ __ ] cop car
yeah that's not a criminal that's a
super criminal man like Lex Luthor
really
that's a penguin and waiting I got two
pieces of tape for you to watch this all
happened right there in front of
Grauman's it's Darth Vader being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] watch it all happening
just going oh I better get out of here
he's like this takes his takes his
lightsaber and it's like a Charlie
Chaplin cane he's just says scooting out
though he's doing this hey take that
horrible kick that's how weak he was and
then Superman interviewed afterwards
saying how he saw the whole thing so
here's the the first is the actual
footage of the crime KTLA
oddly enough reporter was there filming
the whole thing he didn't [ __ ] do a
thing to stop it either by the way and
wasn't and when he told the story called
Superman Batman here's an actual crime
happening on Hollywood Boulevard here's
this guy here busting busting in car
windows with nunchucks
holy [ __ ] nobody's doing it it's a cop
car here's Darth what start alright I
better get I'm out of here yeah I don't
wanna be involved so this guy's slaps
down the laptop here and the kiosk and
starts going through it I wonder if I'm
in here there's Superman hey thanks for
your help Supes yeah the cops show up
finally they caught the guy no harm no
foul I mean he'll go to jail but I don't
know if you're gonna wear the colors you
got to represent right absolutely agree
with you but I would argue that that
that kind of criminal is the one you've
got to be most careful around because he
broke into a [ __ ] cop car took a
computer and waited criminal right actly
what do you need superhero for more yeah
then why so serious you need that that's
the crazy guy you need that superhero
for so I think they've reporter who was
there with the camera crew pulls
Superman aside and says yo Supes what's
up I saw the whole thing
now that the guy
man did anything to stop this crime in
progress you're Superman why didn't you
do anything to stop it
all right it's not my job to jump in the
middle if you're wearing a colors buddy
you could say that if you're an average
ordinary citizen if you're wearing a
[ __ ] cape you can never see anything
off the cops job unless of course your
dad is Kevin Costner and he's taught you
never to put yourself out for anyone
else let the kids in the school bus die
don't save me in the tornado [ __ ] you
it's a new Superman that's the problem
it's not the old Superman if I was that
guy and they were like why didn't you do
anything help it would have been like
kryptonite that would be a better answer
[Music]
you